you know trust in our institutions is
faulty across the board think about it
according to the morning consult tracker
trusting Congress is at 33 percent
that's down 10 from just a year ago the
Supreme Court was at 46 down from 61
percent a year ago the news media I'm
kind of in it it's at 38 and it's listed
as the most polarizing uh U.S
institution great frankly it's not
really surprising last year for example
trust and media hit an all-time low and
it just can't rebound it seems this last
week was has clarified why with why I
have to lie especially when it comes to
the Supreme Court you want to get an
example here we go New York Times Carl
Hulsey writes this about that big
political Roe v Wade ruling Senate
Republicans did not have to take the
politically risky step of banning
abortions the courts took care of that
for them really you would think someone
who's been reporting for more than 30
years could easily have got this right
but he didn't what the Supreme Court
actually did as you know was kick the
decision back back to the States they
did not ban abortion at all yesterday
after the court rejected a case from
health care workers challenging New
York's vaccine mandate the media went
after who else put Clarence Thomas
as long as you're fact checking now do
you mind fact checkings and the Supreme
Court Justice Clarence Thomas who also
wrote that the coveted vaccine is made
from aborted fetuses let me just be very
clear there were no aborted fetus cells
used in any of our vaccines his words
carry such weight and I think that's the
point
let's be clear that's not what he said
that's not what he said at all in his
dissenting opinion he said this Justice
Thomas included a description of the
health care workers belief that some
coveted vaccines were developed using
aborted fetal cell lines it's a lot
different now I also want to point out
this nugget from axios some vaccines
have used fetal cell lines during the
early stages of the vaccine development
got it so let's move on there's also the
EPA ruling which sent the media and the
left into a complete tailspin
the emissions from these power plants we
know are warming the planet they're
causing climate change but today the
Supreme Court curbs one of epa's most
effective tools to drastically curbing
these emissions
all right I guess it's all uh I guess
I'll clear this up for you the Supreme
Court didn't curb epa's power on climate
Congress didn't give them the power in
the first place the Supreme Court merely
affirmed that fact this has been going
on for years by the way it's no wonder
trust in the media is down down hi
everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now